so basically what happened was we saw
loads of these cars heading towards the
desk towards the bridge and then we saw
a man on the ground and you know please
pointing guns at him we were supported
away from the window and then we
returned to the window that a minute
later and a lady was being carried away
from the scene and epital was all I've
seen in a moment
right so you saw as you looked out of
the window just as soon as you were
aware that there was something going on
on the bridge she saw a man on the
ground with police pointing guns at him
then some 10 minutes later you saw a
female being carried from the bridge
joke yeah yes and in terms of the
information that you've been receiving
we could hear the turn away there in the
background or equality information are
you getting no no it's no problem at all
I think we I think we're just getting
another report and live from BBC news at
the moment and yet to seeing
broadcasters through our speakers and
we're located right next to the bridge
we can see it kind of going on at the
moment